we want to figure out what a X plus B
squared is and I encourage you to pause
the video and figure out what that is in
terms of capital A and capital B so
let's work through it this is the same
thing as multiplying ax plus b times ax
plus B so let me fill that in this is ax
there another ax there I just wrote it
in that order
to make the color switching a little bit
easier so ax plus B times ax plus B well
what's that going to be equal to well if
you take this ax and you multiply it
times that ax you're going to get ax
squared ax the entire thing squared and
then if you take if you take this ax and
then multiply it times this B you're
going to get a b x then if you take this
b and you multiply it times this ax
you're going to get another a bx a b x
and then last but not least if you take
this B and multiply it times the other B
it's going to be plus B squared and so
what are you left with well you're going
to be left with a I'll write it like
this a x squared which we actually if we
want well I'll write it in a different
way in a second and then you have plus
plus 2 it's a slightly different color
let me do that other color plus 2 a B X
and then finally plus B squared plus B
squared now I said I could write it in a
slightly different way what I could do
is just rewrite out a x squared as being
the same thing this is the same thing as
a squared x squared and then I can write
out everything else the same way plus 2
a B X and then plus B squared now why
did I what's interesting about doing
this well now we can see the pattern for
the square of
any binomial or binomial like this so
for example if someone were to walk up
to you and say alright I have I have a
trinomial of the form let's say they
have a trinomial of the form 25 x
squared plus 20x plus 4 and they were to
tell you to factor this well actually
let's just do that why don't you pause
the video and see if you could factor
this is the product of two binomials
well when you look at this you see what
look you know this 25 x squared that
looks like a square a perfect square 25
x squared that's the same thing as 5
squared x squared or you could write it
as 5 x 5 x squared this 4 here that's a
perfect square that's the same thing as
2 squared and let's see 20 right over
here if if we wanted to fit this pattern
we would say that a is 5 and B is 2 and
so let's see what would be 2 times a B
well 5 times 2 a B would be 10 and then
2 times that would be 20 so this right
over here is that is plus 2 times 5 2
times 5 times 2 times 2 x times 2x other
than this color times 2 X so you see
that this completely matches this
pattern here where a is equal to 5 and B
is equal to 2 once again this is ax
whole thing squared then you have 2
times a times B X we see that there and
then finally you have the B squared so
if you wanted to factor this you could
say well this is just going to be the
same thing since we know what a and B
are this is going to be 5x + 2 5 X + 2 5
X plus 2 whole thing squared so the
whole point of doing this is to start
recognising when we actually have
perfect squares especially perfect
squares where the leading coefficient
isn't one